bon
Béatrice chère maman dénote oh enfer non je
ne fais pas non non non un peu de chevauchement non non
je ne fais pas assez 70 plantes confirment
juste de totem amusant
[Musique]
aucune batterie n'a survécu ouais pour quoi oui
cette femme parle  l'un des
plus grands défis du nunavik la
contrebande d'alcool un marché noir
extrêmement lucratif pour les trafiquants
rapportant des dizaines de millions de dollars
par an les
bouteilles de vodka vendues au saq 14$
sont revendues illégalement dans le nord pour
100$ 150$ parfois plus c'est au saq que se
trouve l'alcool  est en cours de
contrebande lizzy nuridium général st paul lavond vallabha
Peter Funt surface et les enfants joueront
quand l'alcool de contrebande se retrouvera
dans les communautés il déclenche souvent la
violence il arrive et ceux-ci
reçoivent des appels tout de suite c'est pas de
problème maintenant pas de douleur neshama il y a  un
gars dans le sud il y a une chanson de fan
vraiment il y a une Nissan vraiment une
vraie personne qui se dissipe
piya pad Bella
[Music] la
chanteuse Beatriz cher interprète un
Chanson inuit accompagnée d'enfants de
son village natal de Kwok tock mais
derrière ces sourires innocents se cache souvent une
grande souffrance
c'est pour eux les enfants du Nunavik
la chère Béatrice tire la sonnette d'alarme
elle a posté un message sur Facebook
interpellant les bootleggers qui trafiquent de l'alcool
après vous DOMA  sachez regardez cette devise
que les relations publiques évitent tant d'automates okapis
j'entends qu'ils ont un jour de mois solide Aloha
ne faisant principalement pas ses problèmes d'
alcool et le Nunavik n'est un secret pour personne
ils sont souvent la conséquence de
nombreux traumatismes historiques colonisation
pensionnats et aussi le
l'abattage de leurs chiens de traîneau sanctionné par le gouvernement la
plupart des Inuits ne sont pas alcooliques,
mais l'impact de l'abus d'alcool est ressenti
par tous au point que la plupart des villages
interdisent la vente d'alcool dans leurs
communautés ce qui est autorisé, ce sont les
achats en ligne de bière, de vin et de spiritueux et
des quantités limitées  restrictions qui
ne s'appliquent pas aux bootleggers qui sont ouverts
24h/24 et 7j/7
camilo Neopost Oh Casey n'importe quel médecin de
Mena savait qu'elle avait été un long nom dans l'
e-mail de l'économie magnat, aime-moi retarder
son message a été partagé plus de
700 fois, recevant de nombreux commentaires tous
positifs, c'est si sage de ta part d'avoir le
courage et l'esprit de partager la vérité brute
merci de partager un très
sujet difficile nous avons besoin de plus de gens comme vous
sujet lourd qui est attristant effroi et
frustration nous avons rencontré Béatrice chère
à quark tech un petit village de 450
habitants situé près de la baie d'Ungava
Beatriz nous conduit jusqu'au cimetière en
haut de la colline réédition
patients de collage ctoc quand ils viennent en vain
événement de vendeur er il est reçu de l'autre côté de ce
rideau attendez donc ils n'essaient pas de
dire de la merde à travers le CD peuvent-ils valoir
mille mille toxaphènes aux civils
vous donnez super hawa
attendez monsieur dites plusieurs mois par mois  un
levantese ma batterie de compte à rebours de paiva a
survécu au cas où les accros du dimanche
supposeraient que le traitement proposé à la
télé
une croix placée ici récemment se
distingue pour Beatri  z en mémoire de Janice chère
sa nièce qui s'est suicidée elle
venait d'avoir 18 ans
[Musique] les
bootleggers n'ont aucun scrupule à vendre
aux mineurs fin janvier 2019 un blizzard
frappe élue un village de l'extrême nord du
québec maggie taiaha
avait 15 ans elle y passait la soirée
et une partie de la nuit à boire avec des
amis le lendemain matin son corps a été
retrouvé complètement gelé sous une maison
le rapport du coroner a confirmé l'
hypothermie et l'intoxication alcoolique
ainsi que la présence de cannabis la
vodka que Maggie a bue cette nuit-là a été achetée
à un bootlegger au Nunavik près de 75 ans  %
des crimes sont commis sous l'
influence de l'alcool le tribunal
interdit souvent la consommation d'alcool à ceux
qui sont condamnés mais beaucoup se tournent alors vers les
bootleggers qui deviennent leurs meilleurs clients
période est notre
fête
ce sont les petites bouteilles de 375 millilitres de
vodka ou de Mickey qui sont les plus
populaires le  y vendre pour 100 $ sept fois
le prix régulier mais cela n'arrête pas
les gros buveurs c'est beaucoup d'argent
qui disparaît rapidement Alicia
Erik Goethe a grandi avec une mère qui a
dépensé tout son argent en achetant des
contrebandiers
et cela m'a souvent fait ne pas avoir
les vêtements appropriés ou des vêtements confortables ou des
vêtements de saison et de la nourriture
quand Alicia est devenue adolescente, elle a
commencé à boire comme sa mère quand
j'avais l'âge légal en buvant définitivement au lycée
c'est sûr qu'ils me connaissaient j'étais très bon
Alysia est devenue sobre elle veut donner  sa
fille une meilleure enfance qu'elle n'a eu
J'ai définitivement fait ce choix dans ma vie
que je ne serais pas comme ça même si
j'aime tellement ma mère que
je ne prendrais tout simplement pas les choix qu'elle a
faits dans sa vie mais aujourd'hui pour trop d'
enfants  au Nunavik l'histoire se
répète c'est le déshabillé d'Alfonso il y a une
faible échelle appelée kiss Kevin's vraiment
gal malama timide ces jeunes filles
apprécient le repas que Béatrice leur a
préparé elles sont là pour  voir leur idole
qui traverse une horloge tuck
ces enfants manquent régulièrement de nourriture
ils s'ouvrent à Béatrice
décrivant les difficultés qu'ils endurent à la
maison vous ne pouvez pas voir leurs visages et nous
avons changé leur voix pour protéger
leur identité Carlito donc elle
a dit présenté monsieur
permis pas de jury équitable l'alcool est aussi le
déclencheur de la plupart des violences familiales sirène
ils ne sont pas de retour anticipez un oh elle a
dit que son père Jeremy Perrin a
dirigé je sais que Peter est souvent avec eux
allez tous dire hué
mes parents  réalité icky Mazal constamment
leur détresse est indubitable
si l'on devrait probabilité qu'elle doit avoir
exactement la félicité Manero Manero Manero
matière jour déjà
mr.  journée FET à Manama hot Donna Belial
ou quoi
c'est une soirée de musique rassurante et
un peu de plaisir pour ces filles avant de
rentrer chez elles pour la nuit la
population du nunavik est proche de 14 000
des 14 villages seulement trois autorisent la
vente d'alcool Kujo AK  est l'un de ces
villages il y a deux bars et le
magasin coopératif permet la vente de bière et de
vin pendant des heures limitées la
disponibilité de l'alcool légal dans ces
communautés a eu peu d'impact sur le
marché noir en fait la situation s'est
aggravée autour de qui  est un défenseur actif de
gopala qui publie à perpétuité ne signalez-
vous pas son téléphone portable rouge opposé
nu l'ancre totale avenante dans
la galaxie Je ne
dénonce pas le problème de la
contrebande est une chose pointer du doigt en
est une autre vous savez que c'est une
chose dangereuse si  vous choisissez de commencer à nommer des
personnes qui sont des bootleggers Je pense
que c'est une chose assez dangereuse à faire,
surtout quand vous êtes dans une petite ça
n'aide pas les choses quand le bootlegger
fait partie  de la famille puisque si c'est un
imposteur venu s'exprimer II seulement Nana : /
/ Harvick et enfant Sevilla de retour à
Cujo ACK deux jeunes femmes dont
nous ne révélerons pas les identités pour des
raisons de sécurité nous montrent à quel point il est facile d'acheter de
l'alcool illégal
les premiers contrebandiers  ils contactent le
messager leur revient en moins d'
une minute marchons
qui a conduit une arène désertique de canal sans nœuds
elle se dirige vers la deuxième adresse donnée en
forme - je suis Nikki
Johnny minute de mise à jour
juste euh
qui est censé juste embrasser
il y a  les petits trafiquants et
ceux qui le voient comme une grande entreprise en ce
moment la police enquête sur un
bootlegger de Montréal ses profits dans
les millions que nous connaissons un de cela qu'il a
payé je pense que 60 000 $ ont fait quatre millions
et nous avons trouvé ce bootlegger sur Facebook
il n'y a aucun doute quoi  il vend des
bouteilles de vodka des liasses de billets figurent en bonne place
dans ses photos de profil nous avons demandé à un
collègue de le contacter en se faisant passer pour un
client cherchant à acheter de l'alcool l'homme
qui prétend être dans  Montréal donne
des instructions détaillées Je ne veux pas que les
flics retrouvent l'argent sur le
colis et c'est pour des raisons de sécurité
que vous allez utiliser pour envoyer l'argent
parallèlement à une ligne de jumelles quelle que soit
la transaction censée passer
par ce compte  au Cameroun
avec des photos comme preuve qu'il prétend
expédier régulièrement de l'alcool dans du cannabis par
Postes Canada et Air Inuit, il nous suggère d'
explorer le site Web de son entreprise qui vend
non seulement de la marijuana médicale, mais aussi de la
cocaïne, de l'ecstasy et du crystal meth lorsque nous l'avons
rappelé pour lui demander une entrevue.
refuse de
préciser qu'il pense que c'était la
police que d'autres trafiquants utilisent différentes
méthodes recrutant des intermédiaires souvent des Inuits
pour acheter l'alcool à Montréal qu'ils achètent
principalement à ce saq de Dorval
près de l'aéroport Trudeau de Montréal une plaque tournante
pour les vols desservant le Nunavik ici les
bouteilles de vodka sont pleines  l'affichage juste à l'
entrée des magasins est situé dans les zones où la
vodka éteint un hautain ils commencent
- aujourd'hui nous avons demandé  le saq pour confirmer cette
information l'agence gouvernementale a
refusé en disant que cela risquerait d'entraver
ses intérêts économiques tous les employés à qui
nous avons parlé dans ce point de vente ont confirmé que la
vodka est très populaire et sa
destination finale Nunavik allez donc nous attendons
regardons Ecco comme une fontaine
oui italien
deuxième mère affirmée géniale les
développeurs de Naplouse voyageant oh boy Jana je le
fais totalement à coup sûr vous les chefs le
développeur le saviez seulement pas de problème un
bloc un choc ne lavez pas votre conjoint
kcal / kg disponible dans le même magasin que nous
regardons comme un homme intérieur  remplit son chariot
de bouteilles de vodka ce qu'il fait est
légal mais une fois qu'il sort du magasin,
son comportement est curieux il transfère les
bouteilles dans un sac et ajoute des sacs de
bonbons les produits secs peuvent masquer des
indices révélateurs dit le détective Kenneth Barnaby
fait un bon  son et vous dissuade ils
pensent que nous ne penserons pas qu'il y a de l'
alcool là-dedans il n'y a personne ici pour
éclabousser traversez le couloir jusqu'à la
poste et expédiez-le thi  L'homme
procède exactement à ce qu'il transfère les bouteilles
et les bonbons dans une boîte de Postes Canada
même si l'envoi d'alcool par la poste est
illégal il apporte ensuite le colis
au comptoir destination Nunavik l'
employé ne remarque rien que nous voulions
voir par nous-mêmes à quel point c'est facile  est d'envoyer de l'
alcool dans le nord en sachant que c'est illégal nous
remplissons nos bouteilles avec de l'eau du robinet pour éviter
tout bruit de bruissement de liquide nous ajoutons des
pâtes s'il s'agissait de 35 bouteilles de vodka
le prix régulier serait de 500 $
la même quantité peut être revendue en
quelques heures seulement  au nunavik pour 3500$ un gros
profit nous envoyons deux de nos boites
par first air et air inuit et la troisieme
boite par la poste
destination Kujo AK et quark tank on
verra si elles seront interceptées face a
cet afflux massif d'alcool le  seuls
deux enquêteurs au Nunavik ont bien les mains
pleines nous avons saisi de l'alcool saisi de l'alcool
de contrebande j'étais j'ai été emmen
de partout au Nunavik donc nous n'avons rencontré que d
s personnes de Salawat je pense que je pense que la plupa
t  jours étaient de Salawat certains sont
d'Inuvik
et beaucoup sont d'ici la police s'appuie
sur des appels anonymes du public pour les
aider à trouver des colis suspects en
2019 le montant saisi était évalué à
près de huit cent vingt quatre
mille dollars près du double du
montant saisi le  l'année précédente, nous avons
manqué plus nous avons manqué beaucoup plus nous
obtenons un petit aperçu de ce qui se
passe réellement ici la plus grande
saisie d'alcool au Nunavik s'est produite en 2018 dans une
maison privée à Kujo AK le
retour de Silk Tezuka s'est associé à la
police régionale de karevik Matthew Johnson était
l'enquêteur principal, la perquisition a abouti à
un peu plus de vingt-neuf mille dollars
en espèces, je veux dire environ deux
cent cinquante Mickey, donc dix onces de
vodka et de rhum, trente autres caisses de
bière et avec notre valeur marchande dans le
nord, c'était presque  trente-cinq mille
dollars d'alcool
[Musique]
selon la police, les contrebandiers assistent à l'
interdiction et son fils Sammy a également vendu à des
mineurs qu'ils ont eu t  l'amende maximale en raison
de la quantité d'alcool en espèces qui a
été saisie, mais je veux dire que c'était
environ 4 000 $ chacun en amendes en plus de
l'argent qui a été saisi ce n'est pas
assez ce n'est pas beaucoup pour le genre
d'argent qu'ils gagnent je  d'accord je suis
d'accord avec vous là
-bas les amendes ne sont pas très dissuasives nous avons
trouvé notre 10 interdiction les contrebandiers en
question il travaille dans une épicerie à
Kujo il y a un type d'alcool beaucoup plus
puissant que la vodka qui fait son chemin autour du
Nunavik c'est  le nom n'est pas réglé 94
pour cent d'alcool ces sacs contiennent quatre
litres chacun l'envoi était destiné
au petit village d'Aklavik population
environ 601 375 bouteilles de millilitres qui
sont normalement vendues 26 $ dans le Sud
peuvent rapporter jusqu'à 300 $ sur le marché noir
Natalie appartient  elle travaillait comme infirmière
au dispensaire d'Aklavik
sur la côte d'Hudson elle traitait souvent des
patients fortement intoxiqués avec 94
pour cent d'alcool
il coupait le Mirage pour voir ce qui ne va pas
ou chose EF Evans en tant que tel ce type d'
alco  hol se retrouve souvent entre les mains
d'adolescents mr.  La théorie tunisienne de Dussel
coûte beaucoup plus cher, je veux dire monter en flèche aussi le sel
va-t-il y avoir du
swag tous sonner le pied que mes chats
kikyo-san saucisse il atténue cette
rigidité si je suis le Québec est la
seule province au Canada qui vend
quatre-vingt-quatorze pour cent d'alcool pour la
consommation  c'est interdit ailleurs
parce que c'est jugé beaucoup trop dangereux
[Applaudissements]
jicama l'isaku kirtan branch to go
venomancer Quebec fair paddler shush a
Skilsaw ulema dilemme cut cap table the
de voir que ya de genève un
modèle illégal de con quien do nouveau sur le divan
sur  les passeurs devraient creuser le cas des hôtes
devenus insolubles les employés savent ce qui se
passe mais qu'en est-il de la direction on
voulait demander au président du SI q le
capitaine - non mais notre demande d'entrevue a
été refusée le SI q a répondu par courriel
la sociétaire est Elka du Québec a commencé à
suivre  le problème il y a des mois, dès
que nous avons été informés de la possibilité
que nos produits soient utilisés comme
contrebande,
la réponse a été surprenante car tout le monde a
nous avons parlé au cours de notre enquête a
déclaré que le saq était au courant du
problème depuis des années le monsieur mérite un
spécialiste des sciences sociales doit être gudr un
décideur tonal faire une pose ensemble délicatesse sur la
poche donnons une salade d'un bas
Van de de de smet  assez nous avons besoin de leur
aide et ils savent que c'est pour le
trafic ils savent que c'est à
des fins illégales ce n'est pas vous qui l'achetez
pour vous-même c'est vous qui l'achetez pour le
vendre la société d'État dit qu'une
fois qu'ils ont été mis au courant du problème,
ils ont rapidement contacté le savon  desu ka
la SQ l'a confirmé et dit qu'une
enquête est en cours nous avons aussi demandé à
la saq
pourquoi c'est le seul endroit au Canada qui
vend 94% d'alcool à la consommation
ils ont dit qu'ils reconsidéraient la vente
du produit la saq nous a référé à
la  La Régie des alcools de l'Ontario, qui
autorise la vente d'alcool à 94 % à
des fins scientifiques et médicales,
le saq suivra-t-il cette voie, ils ne
nous diront pas que la police et le Nunavik pointent également
vers l'airli  ne entreprises la
principale façon dont la contrebande trouve son chemin vers le nord
s'il vous plaît un sac en dollars kiyomatsu comme
il y a olympique, disons 40 ans, vous pouvez dépister un
camarade collant peu sûr si excité à
propos de kusenov a
[Musique]
comme nous nous attendions à ce que les bouteilles que nous envoyions soient
arrivées à destination en premier air
et  air inuit sont des subventions de la
corporation mackovic mackovic protège
les droits et intérêts des inuit
ils gèrent aussi l'argent provenant de
la convention de la baie james nord québécois
nous avons eu beaucoup de questions pour son président
charlie watt mais il n'a pas répondu à
notre demande d'entrevue notre  le troisième
conteneur a été envoyé par Postes Canada qui
interdit l'envoi d'alcool par la poste l'envoi
est arrivé sans problème au
bureau de poste COO jock où notre source l'a ramassé ne
peut pas y toucher la police n'a aucune raison d'
entrer au Canada inspecteur des boîtes aux lettres
il n'y a pas d'inspecteur des postes au Nunavik
cata Les inspecteurs de la police régionale de Vic
aimeraient être autorisés à ouvrir
eux-mêmes les envois Postes Canada a également
refusé notre entrevue concernant  quête dans leur
réponse par e-mail, ils affirment qu'ils font le
nécessaire pour intercepter les
expéditions d'alcool et qu'ils
collaborent avec la police, ils préfèrent
ne pas commenter les nouvelles mesures de sécurité
mises en place il y a un an afin de ne pas
entraver leur efficacité mais détective
Johnson  dit que Postes Canada pourrait faire plus à
moins que nous ne fassions plus d'opérations postales franches,
c'est une façon d'empêcher vraiment l'
alcool de monter parce que la poste est un moyen majeur,
mais nous faisons une semaine tous les trois
mois si nous avons de la chance,
une autre façon de ralentir la contrebande serait  être
d'offrir un traitement à ceux qui souffrent
d'alcoolisme ces services
manquent il n'y a qu'un seul
centre de traitement de la toxicomanie au Nunavik le Aswath
Civic Center à Kujo AK qui a du
mal à répondre à la demande un nouveau centre
en construction au coût de quarante virgule
cinq millions de dollars  ouvre ses
portes fin 2021
ère Alysha Goethe qui achetait à des
bootleggers est directeur d'un spécifique
qu'il est difficile de changer quand votre communauté le
fait  ce n'est pas quand votre famille quand votre
conjoint ne le fait pas, c'est pourquoi tout est
civique, ce qui
regarde un programme familial où vous
pourriez passer par le processus non seulement
seul mais avec quelqu'un d'autre aussi donc
[Musique]
il y a huit ans, Beatrice a dû partir
son village pour se faire soigner pour sa
dépendance à l'alcool et pour fuir les
bootleggers le problème Nicola
Javad un jour passe Reseda a Yahweh met
la lumière ah ha ha Concha s'en fout
Beatriz est allée à Montréal à 1800
kilomètres de son village pour obtenir l'
aide dont elle avait besoin problème  se quedó Kovac
mama
Je voulais dire par leur source
Donna Reza Oh Nova suave parle madame
tueuse égoïste peut parler Kennedy une
chère Béatrice parle aussi
souvent qu'elle le peut aujourd'hui elle fait un spectacle pour
aider les femmes autochtones sans abri à
Montréal
[Musique]
métal  jangles aller dire l'essentiel calme
calme profil comparable a dit Alice Paul a
dit dire total Tillman Emma Mayen otaku
Viva Knievel Vanya yep - Tallulah spa
[Musique]